[Música]
para algunas sociedades los abuelos son
figuras respetadas por tu sabiduría
por todo lo que han vivido
por lo que saben y por lo que pueden
enseñarnos hoy les quiero hablar de un
abuelo que puede tener cientos de años
de edad e incluso más de mil años
y no es una locura lo que les estoy
diciendo
estos abuelos son seres muy grandes
tranquilos amables
ofrecen alimentos
en ellos viven cientos de animales
siempre van hacia la luz
están conectados con los suyos y con los
otros
y ellos viven en el bosque
les estoy hablando del chihuahua
uno de los árboles más grandes del
ecosistema amazónico
este árbol que ven en la imagen tiene
800 años de edad
es uno de los árboles más altos del
ecosistema este árbol es un abuelo del
bosque amazónico
y así como algunas sociedades respetan
mucho a los abuelos yo les quiero contar
por qué debemos tener especial aprecio
por estos seres del bosque y porque
debemos aprender a respetarlos
pero que es el chihuahua
el sí guapo es una de las especies de
árboles que más se demora en crecer para
llegar a un metro de diámetro de su
tronco demoran más de 700 años
y para alcanzar el máximo de su
crecimiento pueden demorar mil años
imagínense este árbol desde la foto
ha estado presente y ha convivido con la
humanidad cuando en el perú
recién se desarrollaban las culturas
preincaicas
ha estado de pie en el nacimiento y en
la caída del imperio inca ha sobrevivido
ha sobrevivido
a la época del caucho y sigue de pie
hasta hoy en día
sin embargo
pues haber vivido
tantos años
este este árbol ahora se encuentra en
peligro somos nosotros es decir nuestra
generación la que ha puesto en riesgo su
especie debido a la presión de la
industria maderera
y qué sucede les voy a explicar un poco
este árbol en el momento de crecer
absorbe grandes cantidades de carbono y
las acumula en su tronco es un
acumulador de carbono por excelencia y
esto hace que su madera sea muy dura y
muy resistente lo cual la ha hecho
atractiva para la industria de pisos de
parquet
nos olvidamos los cientos de años que se
ha demorado en crecer y en tan solo dos
horas uno a uno es tumbado para
convertirlo en los pisos de nuestras
casas
esta situación es bastante grave ya que
debido a su lento crecimiento recuperar
las poblaciones naturales de esta
especie será una labor bastante difícil
además aún no cuenta con protección
legal la cual es urgente
pero al perder un árbol de chihuahua que
no sólo perdemos 500 o 1000 años de vida
en sólo dos horas perdemos mucho más que
eso los grandes árboles amazónicos
cumplen un rol muy importante para toda
la selva y también cumplen un papel
vital para nosotros
a qué me refiero vamos a ir por partes
primero debemos tener en cuenta que el
bosque no solo es un conjunto de árboles
sino que son muchos organismos
interactuando entre sí y los árboles
grandes como chihuahua que interactúan y
tienen familias interactúan también con
ellos y se ayudan y colaboran entre
todos
se preguntarán cómo es que funciona esto
cómo es posible pues los árboles están
conectados a una gran red subterránea
formada por sus raíces en simbiosis con
hongos es decir en una relación en la
cual tanto los hongos como las raíces de
los árboles se benefician mutuamente
entre ellos como comparte agua y
nutrientes
mientras los filamentos de los hongos
van creciendo estos ayudan a conectar un
árbol con otro
esta gran red subterránea puede conectar
a un árbol con cientos de otros árboles
y esto ocurre a través de kilómetros
esta interconexión que se da es vital
para el funcionamiento de toda la selva
y estos árboles los árboles más grandes
y longevos a los cuales les llamamos
árboles madres o árboles abuelos
utilizan esta red para ayudar a los
árboles más jóvenes en su desarrollo y
crecimiento y de esta manera los árboles
más jóvenes del bosque tienen mayores
posibilidades de supervivencia de esta
forma los grandes árboles madres o
abuelos se convierten en el soporte de
la vida de la selva
se imaginan entonces lo que significa
cortar uno de estos grandes árboles
es como quitar el soporte de la red que
permite la vida en el bosque y esto es
lo que está sucediendo
pero los árboles no sólo cumplen esta
gran función de interconexión por debajo
de sus raíces
del suelo hacia arriba estos grandes
árboles también tienen un gran valor en
ellos conviven muchos animales y plantas
por eso es que veo al chivo waco como un
puente entre la tierra y el cielo
quisiera que por un momento se imaginen
que estamos debajo del bosque dentro del
bosque aquí dentro no llega mucho la luz
del sol las copas de los árboles sirven
como barreras como techos naturales que
impiden la llegada de la luz esto crea
una gran competencia entre las plantas
y las plantas no se quedan quietas
los grandes árboles sirven como soporte
y como guía para que muchas especies de
plantas puedan llegar a la luz y
desarrollarse para que se den una idea
les les comento de un estudio que se
hizo en la selva central del perú en el
cual se encontraron 190 especies
distintas de visitas en un solo árbol
emergente las plantas epífitas son
aquellas que viven encima de las copas
de los árboles
y no solo las plantas se benefician de
estos grandes árboles también muchos
animales conviven con ellos les podría
mencionar por ejemplo al águila harpía
que es el águila más grande y poderosa
de américa
esta gran águila necesita de los árboles
de chihuahua para poder construir su
nido y esto es así porque cuando el
chihuahua -con llega a su máximo
crecimiento logra extender las ramas de
tal forma que puede ser utilizado por
los pichones del águila para correr y
batir sus alas ejercitando las y
preparándose para su primer vuelo desde
esa altura es decir funcionan como
plataformas de vuelo para los pichones
de esta gran águila sin árboles como el
chihuahua co el águila harpía no tendría
donde anidar
pero no sólo es importante estos grandes
árboles para otras plantas animales y
para la selva que pensarían si les digo
que cumplen un rol vital para nosotros
para nuestras vidas quiero hablarles del
río volador
porque cuando pienso en ese guagua como
un puente no es sólo una metáfora sino
que entre el suelo de la amazonía y el
cielo existe un gran río volador que
conecta a la amazonía con todos nosotros
y no me refiero al río amazon es
ustedes sabían que los árboles funcionan
como bombas de agua que succionan agua
del suelo y las pueden llevar hacia el
cielo
después si un solo gran árbol amazónico
puede bombear hasta y llevar al cielo
hasta mil litros de agua en un solo día
parte de esta agua la absorbe del
subsuelo y la transmite hacia el cielo
por la transpiración de sus hojas
otra parte de esta agua llega de las
lluvias y al ser atrapada por las hojas
y no llega al suelo y se evapora esto se
repite en los más de 300.000 millones de
árboles que existen en la amazonía
toda esta humedad unida a la evaporación
del océano atlántico crea un gran flujo
de humedad atmosférica denominado río
volador
este flujo corre rápidamente por encima
de la amazonía y choca con los andes'
a chocar con los andes' alimentan los
nevados y los glaciares que a su vez
crean ríos y valles en la costa del
pacífico que son la reserva de agua que
todos nosotros tomamos los ríos y los
valles de toda la costa sudamericana
no son sino el deshielo del agua que
viene de la amazonía creada por esta
gran interconexión entre el cielo y la
tierra que se da por medio de los
árboles
la producción agrícola y la vida de
millones de personas en américa latina'
se sustenta gracias a este río volador
creado por la amazonía
y así como les he hablado de chihuahua
que podría contarles también sobre la
canilla o sobre la cat agua o sobre la
gran luna
cada una de estas especies de árboles
madre
con inteligencia y características
propias
yo descubrí la importancia del bosque
amazónico quince años atrás cuando
realizaba las investigaciones de mi
tesis de ingeniería forestal en los
bosques de madre de dios
es en estos años que el estado peruano
comienza un proceso de otorgamiento de
concesiones forestales
se otorgaron varios tipos de concesiones
entre ellas las de reforestación y
porque les cuento esto porque el
problema fue que se estaban otorgando
concesiones de reforestación sobre áreas
que tenían bosque
y que estos bosques podían ser talados
para aprovechar su madera con el
pretexto de después reforestar
reforesta significa volver a plantar
árboles ustedes creen que esta área de
bosque necesita ser reforestados
no es cierto
entonces para evitar que otros tal en el
bosque solicite una gran concesión esta
área y después de un largo trámite me
dieron el aire en concesión y ahí estaba
yo con 916 hectáreas de bosque
qué es el tamaño de todo el distrito de
todo miraflores con 14 kilómetros de
ríos y de quebradas sin saber mucho que
hacer
pero
sabía de la importancia del bosque sabía
que debía dedicar mis esfuerzos para
estudiarlo y lograr su conservación
viajo a costa rica a estudiar un
posgrado en manejo y conservación de
bosques tropicales
en costa rica
hay un incentivo económico por parte del
estado de 60 dólares por hectárea de
bosque conservado
significa que te pagan por conservar el
bosque lo cual me pareció bastante
interesante acá en perú
acá en perú por el contrario yo tenía
las facilidades para talar el bosque y
luego reforestar lo incentivó era el
contrario
entonces regrese de la maestría con el
propósito de poder promover la
conservación del bosque de manera
creativa y poder lograr conservar
es así que se inicia la aventura
[Música]
re queríamos hacer un ingreso al bosque
así que compramos canoa motores equipos
de campo y nos embarcamos en una gran
expedición nos demoramos más de tres
días en llegar al lugar navegando y
después de 33 días de trabajo y de
kampar en el bosque logramos construir
una cabaña
eran solo sin paredes no era solo la
estructura y el techo de palmera pero
para nosotros fue un gran inicio
ahora nueve años después ya tenemos una
estación en el bosque tenemos también
guardaparques vigilando toda el área
gracias al equipo que tenemos en campo y
a mi socias que son mis hermanas este
bosque se mantiene libre de
deforestación con grandes árboles madre
y con abundante fauna silvestre además
realizamos investigaciones y protegemos
más de 500 árboles grandes árboles
centenarios en peligro de tala ilegal
proteger el bosque me ha ayudado a
conectarme con la selva
y sentirme responsable de su bienestar
pero también sé que no soy la única que
está interesada en su conservación
y sé que esta responsabilidad puede ser
compartida
todos hemos sido testigos por las
noticias y redes sobre los incendios que
azotan la amazonía nos duele ver a la
selva quemándose
y muchos nos sentimos impotentes
es por esto
inspirando méndez y guagua con
yo quería llegar a ser un puente entre
las personas y la amazonía
ya sé ya desde el año 2010 arbío
e intenta hacer un puente entre las
personas entre la amazonía y las
personas que están interesadas en ser
parte directa de su conservación
mediante nuestra plataforma web desde
cualquier parte del mundo o aquí
cualquier persona puede adoptar una o
varias hectáreas del bosque que conserva
en conservamos y de esta manera ser
parte directa de la conservación en
convertirse en un defensor de la
amazonía
lo que hicimos fue crear un concepto
nuevo un concepto de conservación
compartida que no es más que poner al
alcance de todos
el poder defender la amazonía desde sus
propios hogares
ahora nos toca a nosotros como peruanos
darnos cuenta de la gran riqueza que
tenemos
más de la mitad de nuestro territorio
está cubierto por bosques
sin embargo le damos tan poco valor
que la mayoría de la madera que se
comercializa y que exportamos proviene
de fuentes ilegales
si alguno de ustedes quiere ser parte de
esta iniciativa son más que bienvenidos
pero además podemos hacer muchas otras
cosas para apoyar la conservación como
ser conscientes o mejorar nuestros
hábitos de consumo
también averiguar y ser conscientes
sobre qué madera estamos utilizando
donar nuestro talento para proyectos de
conservación
la selva amazónica es vital para nuestra
subsistencia tal como hemos visto
nosotros dependemos de ella pero ahora
al mismo tiempo la selva amazónica
depende de nosotros está en nuestras
manos gracias
[Aplausos]